[Music]  you know they say we see everything once  in this cake  pretty sure we've never seen they think  they  this  [Music]  help  you all right i'm fine  the bad news is it's inoperable and that  will start your radiation  [Music]  what's going on with you  i want to know that there's meaning in  the things i do  if you're watching this i'm probably  trying to convince you of something  pretty unbelievable [ __ ]  i'm dead  they do anything to get her back but  this is i mean the next dose could kill  you  they're things that are far worse  than death  [Music]  what happened to him  they're not returning  it's got to be me you can't deal with  reality yeah  the clock keeps ticking down  the time is an illusion  [Music]  you